you've now learned so much about deep
learning and sequence models that we can
actually describe a trigger word system
quite simply just on one slide as you
see in this video but when the rise of
speech recognition have been more and
more devices you can wake up with your
voice and those are sometimes called
trigger word detection systems so let's
see how you can build a trigger word
system examples of triggering systems
include Amazon echo which is broken out
what that word elixir
the by duder OS heart devices woken up
with face duty how Apple Siri working
out with hey Siri and Google home woke
up with okay Google
so Stan's the trigger word detection
that if you have say an Amazon echo in
your living room you can walk the living
room and just say Alexa what time is it
and have it wake up I'll be triggered by
the words of exer and answer your voice
query so if you can build a trigger word
detection system maybe you can make your
computer do something by telling it
computer activate one of my friends also
works on turning on an offer particular
lamp using a trigger word kind of as a
fun project but what I want to show you
is how you can build a trigger word
detection system the literature on
trigger word detection algorithm is
still evolving so there isn't wide
consensus yet on what's the best
algorithm for trigger word detection so
I'm just going to show you one example
of an album you can use now you've seen
our n ends like this and what we really
do is take an audio clip maybe compute
spectrogram features and that generates
features x1 x2 x3 audio features x1 x2
x3 that you pass through an RNN and so
all that remains to be done is to define
the target labels Y so if this point in
the audio clip is when someone just
finished saying the trigger word such as
a lecture or seralini ha or history or
okay Google then in the training sets
you can set the target labels to be zero
for everything before that point and
right after that to set the target label
and then if a little bit later on you
know the trigger word was set again and
the trigger what was said at this point
then you can again set the target label
to be one right after that now this type
of labeling scheme for an RNN you know
could work actually this won't actually
work reasonably well one slight
disadvantage of this is it creates a
very imbalanced training set to have a
lot more zeros than once so one other
thing you could do that's it's getting a
little bit of a hack but could make them
although a little bit easy to train is
instead of setting only a single time
step to output one you can actually make
it output a few ones for several times
over a fixed period of time before
reverting back to zero so and that's
slightly evens out the ratio of ones to
zeros but this is a little bit of a hack
but if this is when in the audio clipper
trigger where the set then right after
that you can set the target label to 1
and if this is the trigger where it said
again then right after that is when you
want the RNN to output 1 so you get to
play more of this as well in the
programming exercise but I think you
should feel quite proud of yourself that
you've learned enough about the learning
that it just takes one picture in one
slide to this to describe something
that's complicated to this trigger word
detection and based on this I hope you'd
be able to implement something that
works and allows you to detect trigger
words when you see more of this in the
program exercise so that's it for
trigger words and I hope you feel quite
proud of yourself for how much you've
learned about deep learning that we can
now describe trigger words in just one
slide in a few minutes and that you
better hope philemon and get it to work
maybe even make it do something fun in
your house if I might turn on or turn
off or you can do something my computer
when you're when someone else
they trigger words on this is the last
technical video of this course and wrap
up in this course on sequence models you
learned about our n ends including both
gr use and LST ms and then in the second
week you learned a lot about word
embeddings and how they learn
representations of words and then in
this week you learned about the
attention model as well as how to use it
to process audio data and I hope you
have fun implementing all of these ideas
in this beast program exercise let's go
on to the last video